à recife
la marseillaise a résonné devant l'hôtel
de ville de rambouillet lundi 26 avril
pour rendre hommage à stéphanie m
cette fonctionnaire de police assassiné
trois jours plus tôt dans le
commissariat de la commune
des centaines d'habitants se sont
déplacés pour soutenir sa famille et ses
collègues
je suis révoltée par l'intolérance et
que et que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
choqué beaucoup parce que les enfants de
cette dame pourrait être mes petits
enfants parce que parce que je pense à
la famille qui restent et que se faire
tuer comme ça en allant au travail je
trouve ça épouvantable
certains sont venus de plus loin en ile
de france pour dénoncer ces actes rendre
hommage mais aussi faire passer un
message
je dénonce cet acte barbare c'est une
mère de famille qui a laissé des enfants
et
je suis venu dire que l'islam c'est pas
ça l'islam c'est une religion de
tolérance de paix et de foi je ne sais
pas au nom de qui pourquoi il a tué
cette pauvre dame qui n'a rien demandé
ministre président du sénat députés
autour de la maire de rambouillet de
nombreux élus ont fait le déplacement
je veux une d'abord pour rendre hommage
à stéphanie à cette personne qui a été
assassinée sauvagement cet attentat qui
a eu vendredi à rambouillet pour rendre
hommage à cette personne pour rendre
hommage à ses enfants ses deux filles et
son mari parce que ça a eu aujourd'hui à
la qui je pense une cérémonie sobre
courte à la demande de la famille
vendredi 30 avril un hommage national
sera rendu
présidée par jean castex